[Music]  hey hey hey hey hey wait a minute  but first Alan [ __ ] stars in instinct  premiering this Sunday on CBS  he's a former CIA agent turned professor  and author a career switch he makes to  please his husband I think it's the  first Network drama in American  television to ever ceilidh I thought  that's a really big deal that's that  needs to be done and if it needs to be  done I'm the man to do it okay you don't  have to admit I was right Whoopi  Goldberg co-stars as his book editor  there's a lot of love between these two  real-life friends but their love of food  couldn't be more different I'm confused  are you enthusing about your empanada it  was a vegan empanada because Alan is a  vegan and I looked at it I did not put  it in my mouth because I need some meat  sorry vegans I need some meat  [Music]